so hi everyone I'm Jeremy and today
we're going to look at some examples of
interactive user
Asians built with pixie Jas and GPO
widgets but don't worry there won't be
too much of JavaScript so you can find
me on on Twitter on github and also can
I have a look at my website for similar
projects but first of all it's good to
just stop for a while and look at what
we have when we want to make
visualizations in Python so there is
already a lot of tools a lot of
frameworks and as you can see here on
the map they are actually clustered in
different categories so if you are in
that part so on the right side there is
more about using tools with a an API
close to Madrid clip but for us in our
case we'll be looking more at the red
cluster so that's the JavaScript cluster
so this map was presented by Jaguar no
class at PyCon 2017 and it's a good
reference to know where to start when we
want to make visualizations but for us
it would be more like going really in a
niche case so using a library that is
not even shown on this map for very very
specific use cases alright so the
motivation basically is to not have what
you have on left but what you have on
the right so really like something not
like typical bar chart or typical
scatter plots but more something like
interactive and moving and maybe just
simple shapes such as squares and
circles all right
so first of all Jupiter lappy suggests
and trippy widgets might be a lot to
take in at once but Jupiter lab if you
are not using it yet this is basically
what you're seeing right now in a
browser so it's the next generation UI
for GPU notebooks so I really encourage
you to try it out if you haven't done so
yet it adds a bunch of features for
support FoxPro here you can look at your
files you can integrate it with a lot of
extensions you can even have terminal
and split windows and everything we look
at it a bit later all right pixie Jas
it's a powerful 2d rendering engine
written in JavaScript so it's made for
the web and it's an abstraction on top
of canvas and WebGL so we don't have to
deal with too much with all of the
internals of WebGL and how it works but
instead we can choose
use an API there is a slightly slimport
to to use as an end user so here we have
an example this is basically canvas with
a blue background and a bunny in the
middle of the screen rotating so how do
we do this this is just as simple as
creating an application a pixie
application loading the sprite for the
bunny putting into the middle of the
screen and then in pixie dress there is
no this notion of ticker which is
basically a function that will be called
at each frame and here at for each frame
we just rotate we add a ribbit of Delta
to the rotation all right finally GPIO
widgets it's a framework for building
interaction interactively relation in a
browser so it's even more than that
actually it's just a framework to make
it easy to sync data between the kernel
and the fronton so when you use a Drupal
notebook you have a back-end which is a
kernel it can be in Python it can be in
other language but in our case you have
in Python and you have a front-end which
is a mix of JavaScript and HTML and here
in for the triple of widgets framework
the idea is you create an object on the
Python side and then there will be a
counterpart object created on the other
side and then you can start modifying
some attributes and the values on the
Python zone and it will be automatically
synced with the front-end and you can do
the same the other way around
so I think it would be better to just
look at an example so here we have the I
PI widgets library which is the official
widgets library built for Python and
we're going to create an insulator that
goes from 0 to 10 so we can interact
with it right now but we can also ask
the notebook to show a second view for
the same widget so there we go so we
have the same view for this for the
object we created using the in slider
and we are basically in that scenario
where we have two views for the same
object and then we can access the value
of that object in Python and we can also
set it and it gets automatically synced
between the back end and the front end
right you can create your owners really
good tutorial on the official
documentation and of course there are
already some libraries built on top of
that and very mature
so the cupid for example is using d3.js
on the front-end to make this kind of
interactive visualizations there is a PI
flat for displaying maps in a browser
there is also a PI volume to show 3d
contents in a browser so it's built on
top of 3GS but for us way back to this
little animation style so how do we do
we display something in a notebook like
this all right so first of all let's
look at what we have here so this ipod
is packaged is basically just running on
this machine this is a local Python
package just standard and it exposes
this simple shape class so let's look at
the implementation of this class very
quickly so you can see that in
inheriting from this demetrite which
comes from this ipad Widgit and here we
have a bunch of metadata for the widgets
communication and here we have a flag
user-defined flag for enabling or
disabling
a feature I will just see what it looks
like afterwards and here let's put it on
the side all right so that is on the
right that is the the front-end part of
this widget so we have a model here
which also comes from the GPO widgets
library so it's we extend this base
model and then we can add our everything
we want to be synced between the two the
two parts and then we have the view and
the view is basically where the Big C
application will be created so we create
the pixi application there and similar
to the bunny thing we saw just before we
create the graphics then we can call
some line style then we finally draw our
rectangle in the middle we position the
shape the center of the screen and then
we have the ticker back and we are this
is where we read the rotate flag which
is defined here and the Python side
and whenever we rotate with change
rotations so similar to the bunny
example but this is created from from
scratch using the iPad which at library
and when we when we finally make use of
this so let's close this panel and yeah
so instantiate the Python object and we
asked a notebook to displayed for us so
we get our square in the middle similar
to the bunny and then we can activate
this flag and we get it rotating because
this is what we implemented in a pixie
application right so building on top of
this so the entire presentation will be
just starting from this video the
example and try to make a bit more
elaborated use cases building on top of
this we can just say okay
draw me a hundred shapes in that case
it's circles we can make sure that is
actually a circle by just asking Python
to give us the value for this shape
attribute but we can change it here and
it gets propagated to the front end so
it's about a little bit yeah and similar
to what we saw before we can just start
any being flags we can also add another
one a would flag where we get whatever
user-defined behavior we want to
increment and yeah so I hope you got the
idea of the intent of this kind of
visualization so that we can start
looking at something a bit more
elaborate in May and also maybe a bit
more useful so in our case we start
looking at a puzzle so this is a puzzle
a wooden puzzle and there are 16
triangles and the goal is to put them
all in in a big one and there is one
constraint is that the corals need to
match so for example if you look at the
one at the bottom right here we have
black matching with black and green
matching with green and then we have to
continue adding all of the other
triangles so that they there is no
conflict of course basically so of
course you can stop playing with this
like this like if you have the toy
puzzle with you just try to make your
way and see if you can find solution but
you can also go the the other the other
route and try to solve it
programmatically and since we're in
notebook since we are using PC players
we can also make use of all of these
tools and just build on top of them
to draw a visualization right in
because you might want to solve this
puzzle chromatically but then without
the visualization it can be hard to know
whether you actually found the solution
or not when we have this kind of really
visual problems it's much nicer to have
something like the direct feedback in a
browser so let's look at what we have
here so to spare you the details of
implementing a visualization for this
this is all encapsulated in this widget
so the widget was built in following the
same style as the previous example but
we can just use it right here in a
browser so what we see we get our canvas
we get our six triangles aligned on the
right and then we have all of the colors
everything and we also have additional
controls and those controls come from
the iPad widgets library so the cool
thing with the whole jupiter widget
framework is we can reuse a lot of stuff
and we can connect them together so we
will see later what happens when we
click on buttons so the idea is you can
add some kind of hooks and then whenever
you click on the button you can trigger
an action on the canvas all right so
what can we do with this widget
the idea is to also be able to visualize
animations so be able to visualize
transitions between states so like we
stopped playing with with the toy in
real life we start placing triangles and
we will add a new one but it would be
cool if we could see those triangles
moving around and see what's happening
under the hood when we start solving
such a problem all right so in our case
a state is basically just a list of 16
elements corresponding to the 16
triangles here we have a triangle number
13 zoom a little bit triangle number 13
with rotation one at the first position
and here we have another one the number
12 with rotation zero so rotation is
encoded as a any danger from zero to two
zero one two to show whether we are
rotating the triangle or not all right
so now we have a model for the state and
we can see how we can use it in our
little little widget so here we pass a
bunch of test States so we have here
empty and T state so there's nothing and
then we start pressing triangle server
we rotate it one time we'll rotate two
times then we add a triangle zero we
rotate it again and then we bring
everything on the board and we were to
rotate everything one time to the to the
left and this is how it looks like so
this is time to make use of these little
controls so maybe it's time to make it
slower alright so we have our triangle
number seven brought on the board
rotating three times and then we have
number zero that we bring rotate one
time and then we bring everything at
once and we rotate everything at once if
we don't want to do we already smelly we
just click the play button and this
thing will be looping all the time and
if we are bored we can also speed it up
so it goes faster and then we also have
extra buttons such as start and end to
go from the beginning to the end on and
so on
all right or use this little slider here
to go a specific position in this list
of states all right so that's our tool
that's what we have now we're finally
ready to solve the puzzle in Python so
the idea again is to really not touch
JavaScript at all and just have the
interface in Python so that we can
actually implement the algorithm there
in a notebook and let the visualization
do the job of showing us feedback all
right so here is an interface and you
can see here this is the sort method
that is not implemented and that we're
going to implement we can make use of
the loc method which is basically just
taking a snapshot of a current state
that we can append to this big list and
then visualize later and there is also
this fun method which is going to check
all of the triangles whether they have
any conflict in terms of colors or not
and here's basically checking for all of
them that they are they're actually good
so is valid might be a really tricky to
define this one first bit tricky to
understand what it means so it's taking
an integer I that corresponds to the
position of a triangle to check between
0 and 15 inclusive is returning a
boolean which will be true if the
triangle at position I doesn't have any
conflict of colors otherwise it will
return for
and if we look at this example here for
triangle number seven we see that right
is matching with red but black is not
matching with white so it's going to
retain force and we can make use of this
API that was defined in a widget itself
so that the person consuming the widget
can reason about the problem in a much
easier way alright so first try why not
just randomly sample the whole board and
see what happens so 200 times take a
random permutation of the board and then
take a snapshot so the Queen visualized
it check if it's found if it's found
then we just say okay we stop and we can
execute this unfortunately we don't
didn't see our little print which means
that we didn't find the solution and
which is expected because just searching
randomly like this doesn't bring us
anywhere so yeah it's just a little
warm-up to be able to play with this
widget so we can continue like this 200
times but we can also spare the pain and
go directly to the end and of course it
doesn't match but at least we have a
very direct feedback we know oh this is
wrong and we can move on all right so
now we're going to look at a better
implementation so in our case we'll be
using a brute force approach so by just
recursively placing all the triangles
one by one and then when there is one
there it doesn't match anymore we just
remove it from the pod so the typical
recursive problem and here the method
for that is it's called place and it's
taking the position of the triangle we
want to place at that time and in the
recursive approach there is always a
base case in our case it would be
whether we have placed off the triangles
or not if they are all on the ball it
means that we managed to place them all
without any conflict divorce we missed
it we finally found the solution
otherwise we have to go through all of
the other triangles are left check
whether they are used or not if they
lose we skip if they are not use we'll
just mark that - used and then we go
through all of the rotation this is
where we take the snapshot to be able to
visualize what's happening when we
rotate the triangles and then we finally
make use of our little is valid function
for that particular triangle and if this
one is saying okay this is valid then we
can continue and
recurse one more time by checking
triangle number i plus one
and if none of this works then it's time
to undo the thing and also take snapshot
there so let's run this and run this
okay what we get is we are we found a
solution and also 10,000 steps so take a
long time to look at all of this stuff
I'm kidding but we won't be looking at
one by one so we can just display it
again with the same widget and start
yeah going through the entire thing here
so let's slow it down a little bit maybe
repeat more all right so as you can see
here we go just go from in the list we
just place them one by one and there
here we are looking for white and blue
we found one we just leave it on the
board where we're looking for a red car
oh you're so fun one we leave it there
and so on and the idea is to is to see
when we implement such a thing what
happens so you can move move on and see
for iteration number 100 3700 so it's
looking good it's looking good but we
still haven't 9000 left so it means that
at some point there is some backtracking
involved because one of the previous
choices was wrong and we have to go back
to to the beginning in some way but we
can just let it play on its own and see
what happens ah it's the end yeah so and
now in seconds we finally have our
answer and yeah we can double check all
of the single course one by one but
that's it that's the solution and we
don't have to just check one by a like
we will get an array instead of numbers
it would be much much harder to know
whether we have find a found a solution
or not so that's basically it and this
example has more details if you look at
this article there so it's also using a
different library so b5j s which is
similar to pixie Jas
but yeah so if you're interested in also
how to create the JavaScript part of
visualizations then you can check out
the code on github you can also run it
on binder without having to install
anything on your laptop but now let's go
back to let's go to new with something
even more elaborated so let's talk about
games a little bit and how to view
States of games all right so the game
going to talk about is called Prospero
and it's developed at Google where I'm
currently working at and it's a hidden
object game it's available on Android on
iOS and also on Facebook as a WebGL game
alright and it looks like this so this
is the core core game so it's a hidden
object games it means that you get rid
of items of objects you have to find in
the scene and faster you find them the
more bonuses you get the more points you
get and then you can use two points and
bonuses to buy items that you can place
on your island so the main character has
an island which is actually yours and
then you can start placing yeah
buildings decorations and so on you can
buy cash you can use your coins and so
on so in our case is this game a player
has a progression so how far in a story
the player is but there is also a
representation of this island for the
photo player and this is basically just
a JSON file so it stored like that like
a bunch of metadata for all of the items
and sometimes what we get is requests
from players because they left the
device to their kids and the kids they
just started to play with the game and
deleted every single item and then they
asked us can you please restore my game
state as it was two weeks ago or so and
we have a tool like this for customer
care and they can use it to actually
check the state of a player at a given
time and then help the players to go
back to where they were before so this
is a tool written in pixie J's and it's
also running in a web browser and it was
offered by a colleague of mine Benedict
also working at Google and basically
have I don't even know how this thing
works inside but it doesn't really
matter because here what I would like to
show is how we can actually make use of
the same tool which was which is used
here in my customer care but in a
different context and in this context
would be a trippy Renaud book all right
so under goal for that I mean why would
we want to have access to such a widget
well once we have a previous state in
JSON we can start playing with the
player state itself using Python and
this is whatever I wish
right now so let's look at a clear state
first so this is a list of objects of
dictionaries where we have x and y to
show the position of the item on the
island and we also have the type of item
that is at this particular position all
right and this is our widget and we can
create a widget here and we can set the
state that we just displayed before and
we can just ask the notebook to show the
widget for us so we get our widget here
and this corresponds to the state we saw
before and since it's exactly the same
tool we can just use the exact same
features so we can zoom and hover on
that and just explore a state of a
player directly in energy repeater but
then we can do more we can start looking
at what happens if I replace the state
we have here by another state so here we
have another example and you can see
that the widget is going to pick up the
change on the state attribute and
because this stator field was propagated
from the kernel to the front end and
then on the front end we can pick up
that change and show the new state in
real time all right so we can also use
this kind of tools here to actually
modify the state in in in real time so
here using the notebook so for example
we can just say okay just display me
half of the items on the island so now
we are going to restart reload the
entire island but it's half empty and we
can also use this kind of widget to just
build a state from scratch and make
maybe do some kind of experiment see how
people where people place their their
items on the screen and on the island so
for that we can just say for example
let's use position X 15 and then put all
of the items in a straight line so if we
execute this we see that they are indeed
coming up in a straight line completely
arbitrary we can do something a bit more
advanced and if we change that for
example not 15 but 25 then now we are
using X 25
so that's basically it that's basically
the kind of visualization you can make
when you start leveraging the entire
JavaScript ecosystem and the that was
the recap and in terms of applications
so as we saw it's quite a nice tool to
be able to actually see what's happened
what's happening so for example in the
case of the little puzzle let's say you
have an assignment for a student and
it's a university or whatever and you
don't want them to bother too much with
the visualization so you just okay here
is the widget here is how you can see if
whether your assertion is good or not
and now it's time to implement your
algorithm so I think this is the kind of
thing we're starting to see already in
this whole JavaScript roster if you
remember a map in the beginning where we
have interactivity using existing
JavaScript libraries but I think it's
it's really great for this kind of
applications and then yeah and then now
we are starting to look at actually
games written in in javascript in the
browser and in our case in repeaters so
we can there are tons of applications we
can do with this of course there is one
downside which is that you have to build
this whole new transition so in that in
that case it's implemented in a mix of
typescript and JavaScript so you have to
put the effort to actually create that
visualizations and as we saw here it was
really like for specific use case so of
course it's not like as generic as this
kind of PQ plot libraries that we saw in
in the beginning all right so there are
a bunch of references on the Drupal
widgets a lot of very very good work
already done you can really have a look
at that and of course if you have any
questions right now is the right time or
you can also ask them on Twitter github
or my website thank you for listening